foreign
[Music]
amusement park today
this one looks like it's more visual so
am I checking you're allowed to come
they do have a Godzilla Ryan it's a
shower amusement park so it's happy
everyone happy and good till then but
first we're stopping for some Italian
food big Japanese Italian chain here we
never actually tried it so we'll see if
my table the pro or I you know I have a
fine Italian taste now thank you very
much we'll see
[Music]
let's bring it overcooked it was good I
think I turn myself but we're gonna get
snacks at the theme park gotta be a
responsible idols
it is empty
[Music]
it's 37 degrees
very humid
I'm wearing long sleeve because I didn't
a lot of tattoos it's a good thing we're
wearing full sleep because he was
totally like checking out if we had it I
was like why is he staring at us
everything is in Japanese which is cool
I get it it's shower so they don't want
to put it English stuff prettier than I
thought actually
[Music]
foreign
I think the fact that there's no English
text really like makes you feel like you
enter another
time
[Music]
best part of summer in Japan
oh my God
it's just flavored eyes but that's all
you want when it's this hot
[Music]
[Applause]
all right time to practice put my kanji
practice to test
uh
that was like one of the first scary
rides I ever went to
and after I did that one I was like I
can do anything now
they have a giant octopus
that's not running where's that Godzilla
ride
what's that
so much Wonder
feels very empty I guess a lot of people
don't go on a weekday yeah it took it
took a while to get here it's super it's
totally worth it I really like it so far
at least but I don't wonder how much
there is to do
there's the water slide
there's a man swimming on the ocean
got a lot of stuff uh it's not open
we're going to take the train because as
much I can do that one honestly I love
that there's no one here it makes it so
much more enjoyable to be at a theme
park even if everything is gone
I decided to go on the
sauna you know it's kind of fun
you lie to me
was the AC not invented in the 1940s
we just left the train and now we're
like oh it's so cold outside
it was so hot in there now I'm sweating
before I was okay oh spray me
hello what is that all right let's find
the actual train we wanted to go to
[Music]
go to
it's closed we picked up some merch TV
Godzilla
very cute I got like a short sleeve
shirt I feel like that would be really
nice right now
but I'm not allowed to wear it I might
step on a knife
cute t-shirt
[Music]
oh no
too hard
[Music]
oh no
I know this evening
[Music]
that concludes our showa era amusement
park it is it it was really fun no luck
with the games or the rides
but you know my son needs to walk a lot
now because she's really close to her
delivery giving birth
so it's good we got our steps in
[Music]
interrupting video for sponsor and baby
here to destroy thank you everyone who
supported the new merch drop very nice I
can't seem to keep them clean for
whatever reason for everyone I missed
out on the first drop don't worry
because we got two more available right
now in Ray and off-white looking very
nice you can also find a dead cam get it
and a hoodie too all part of the father
of YouTube collection only available for
three weeks so if you want to check them
out it's a limited availability as same
as lifetime don't wait or get shamed go
to pdpstore.com check them out thank you
for supporting appreciate it the Vlog
continues
[Music]
what's going on got Mr B in the bank our
first outing
as a fan let's see how this goes we're
going to a mall because we figured
that'd be easy and I have to poop
probably Beyond Two
we have to buy it
Brianna I have bad news for you
there's an imposter
I say it's the biggest fan
[Music]
it's your birthday Mama
today is mama's birthday happy birthday
Mama one year old we went here with Matt
Mayan anger's birthday so it's almost
time and she gets the cake and she's
gonna eat it like a psychopath though
I'm sure
she sees the food going back what is
that
[Music]
which one do you want
he's like whatever just give me the
pizza
oh I gotta take a photo of that
happy birthday to Mama
happy birthday Mama it's over mama
[Music]
Coke Zero melons
we're gonna have a kakigori Peach flavor
I feel like this is our life now
going to diners family restaurants you
get to pick your menu
I heard that Americans that come to
Japan to the dinosaur get really like
weird like where am I
feast
if you go to Denny's get the garlic rice
it's the bomb and they have a spiral
meat I like the generous portion of
potato
almost
didn't like Peach that much overrated
fruit
all right
this is actually a
Swedish dessert comes from our backyard
you just eat snow
um
we're sitting in line 30 minutes we're
going to the shiningawa aquarium in case
I didn't tell you and then I'm going
bouldering after so today we'll be
did he fart again I don't think he can
hear it so gambling here in Japan is
illegal
but boat raising is okay so it's one of
the many things people do
oh you can't really see it but they were
just coming by Joey told me about this
he said it's really fun to watch
hell yeah they're super tiny boats
yeah
look at this little toes
almost
oh my God
it says underwater we're going on the
water wheel is just trying to go down
everyone's trying to go underwater I'm
so confused I don't know if I want to do
this
okay
[Music]
wow
Lagoon aquarium tunnel the emergency has
spotted puffer fish
foreign
[Music]
fish
oh my God
it speaks damn these look like leaves
that's so cool but they're fishes
whoa
[Music]
uh that's super pretty we just did a
quickie because it's we're kind of new
with bringing yarn out and it's also
very hot it was easy in there obviously
but ravion is great he loves his baby
beer
people were saying I was wearing it
wrong it has to be like Kiss distance
but look
what is that then
[Music]
oh dude close
foreign
at the moment I do the morning and much
to do the night
why am I speaking too loud huh but it's
been working out good it's been kind of
cranky this week but he's sleeping more
now which is really good so I think it's
going better and better what is all this
thought babies were bold see I usually
just spend the morning studying Japanese
which is nice I've been having more time
to do that he sleeps in his bed too it's
just he happened to pass out like this
so I don't want to move him
[Music]
it's our anniversary
so we're going to a museum and then
having some dinner immersion Museum
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
having so many Italian food and The View
had a really nice meal
I'm very full I need to hold the camera
here when I Vlog but I feel so awkward
in public going back to Baron
are you happy to see Daddy
yeah
it's very cozy being a dentist
sleeping baby is the best baby
we weren't sure like how much of yarn we
would show but he's such a big part of
our lives that it sort of happens and
he's so cute I can't help but I wanted
to show him
I just think it'd be fun to see like I
would love to see
videos of me as a kid more well edited
by professional editor Marzia
um today we are continuing our sort of
anniversary because we rented a house in
Chiba where I like to go and Surf and
hopefully we'll get a little break from
the city heat and hopefully I'll the
waves are good so I can serve we'll see
it's the first time we go traveling with
Byron it's only two hours away so if
everything hits the fan we can always
just drive back home it feels so good
that we have a babysitter now because
obviously like our grandparents aren't
here so it's just been me and Marzia
every single day and I think after a
while you just need a break so you
started to feel like
things are getting more into motion and
getting a better swing of things and we
get good suggestions by our babysitter
that helps and it feels really good I'm
actually starting to like the little guy
even though he poops on my hands
and it feels like you do it on purpose
you wouldn't poop on Daddy on purpose
right
[Music]
[Applause]
good day to you mate
it's also PewDiePie here
[Music]
mommy went to pee
we are in Chiba and uh surfboard is on
the roof we packed every single baby
item there is in the car
[Music]
there's another Chihuahua
hope the dogs love it this is really
nice from what I've seen so far you guys
get a whole backyard finally yay Matt
says feeding beer in the car yeah I
should unpack I'll show the place later
well mama loves the place
what do you think beer
we're right next to surigasaki which is
my favorite Beach I didn't know so we're
gonna go hard tomorrow while mommy stays
does Mommy stop
so much stuff to set up and we forgot
the baby bouncer it's uh it's a bit
cooler out here because obviously we're
not in the city but it's still pretty
hot I would say so pretty though I
really like this iron we stayed here
nearby on my birthday last year
[Music]
oh my God I there's the biggest spider
here you see I'm sorry I'm scared beer
and I'm so freaked out by the spider oh
I'm sorry
oh my God there's three of them
uh
oh
disgusting
[Music]
finally the day has come
I get to Surf again
I feel like such a goofball with this
hat but the sun don't play around so I'm
at one of my favorite beaches
world's first ever Olympic
Beach
which is very cool waves are looking
about a meter high
it's not the best but uh it'll do I
forgot my GoPro so I can't film
that guy's filming so maybe I will find
some footage online of me is landing on
my face
[Music]
I'm so tired but I'm going out again uh
just taking a break and drink some water
it's super fun the waves are bigger now
they're like two meters there's some
really good servers out there had a one
big wipe I almost lost my hat but I rode
some pretty big ones so this felt really
good good control now I feel like I'm
finally getting pretty decent
I try to film myself but I was out of
frame the whole time that was such a
good wave I got at the end I was like
rushing back to see if I caught it on
camera
[Music]
foreign
I might go out again after I eat I have
contact lenses so my eyes get so red
going to have lunch now
which I am starving for and my
bouldering hands
in the water Marissa's gonna love that
hey I tumbled a little bit I'm not gonna
lie oh my God
how much can fit in my nose new wetsuit
day two of surf just kidding it's the
same day I fixed my hat
I'm not gonna get many chances to Surf
so
I've only done it for two and a half
hours so
we keep going I'm gonna be really tired
tomorrow
[Music]
back on the beach for the third time
today but this time everyone is here
Momo still hasn't gotten over sand I
think he he's like whatever
[Music]
still good waves my arms are so tired it
hurts to hold that phone up oh yeah
we're taking a little walk because it's
a nice breeze and what did you find
Nikki damn it's bigger than your brain
Edgar
[Music]
what the hell happened
big day today
a little one
we're registering him as a citizen of
Sweden we're going to do Italy as well
Mr worldwide hopefully it all goes well
all these things are always so
complicated
they moved damn Missy I feel like super
dead right now
there's so much going on we'll see how
this goes again muncher couldn't come
because only one person I don't even
know if I have to bring beer and I think
I do past two weeks Buren has been very
fuzzy you put him down and he cries you
have to hold him like all the time
they say they go through like growth
spurts certain weeks so I hope that's
been the case because you seem much
better now you never know every baby's
different
are you
looking for trouble again
Oppenheimer isn't shown in Japan so
we're going to see the Barbie movie
wish we would have washed anyway
I stopped myself from saying it's so
high you know I'm not gonna do it
but it is very hot damn it we have a
babysitter now which is amazing we can
leave the house for a couple hours and
what else would you do with your time
[Music]
[Applause]
Barbie movie was so funny it's probably
not even showing anymore by the time
this Vlog comes out but we were laughing
so much
I think I feel like we were the only
ones laughing though
it happens sometimes in Japanese
theaters I don't know if it was like the
humor but I thought it was hilarious
here I am
here's mama
we are so cozy over here guys
we are at a giant Outlet we've been here
before
that again Maya rest in peace we're
going to the snooky Museum because Marta
got us tickets for free thank you Snoopy
Museum there he is
for some reason Snoopy is really big in
Japan
[Music]
you guys having fun
I remember this huh
[Music]
or again like a private tour here
there's no one in the home Museum so far
so that isn't
oh I'm almost
[Music]
today I'm going bouldering I'm very
excited because also Marzia is coming
she's been pregnant what an excuse to
get out of bouldering recently finally I
can go instead of just coming back home
being like I climbed a really good thing
today I can be like look I didn't think
you're gonna have some lunch first
and then we climb till we die
[Music]
big blender I forgot my shoes damn it
well done
[Music]
she's stepping up in grades
probably yeah oh she did it at somehow
[Music]
nice
that's it you got it
yay
nice you did it nice
let's go
get it so good
well done I'm super impressed that was
really cool way more fun to then alone I
go with Connor sometime I think I did
okay considering it was rental shares
oh they were slippery shoes I'm not
gonna lie and my toes oh my God my toes
are so red
anyway back to baby we met a couple
there
was really lovely
um they were Japanese but they had been
studying in Sweden Gothenburg actually
and they were there with their 10 month
old I think it was yeah and you better
watch out you're gonna climb real soon
no they were just there because they
were allowed to bring it it's a fun
social Sport and you got the feel of
that too man
we stopped at a book off they sound like
used items Donkey Kong 2 I love that
game
900 Yen that's it
what PlayStation game is this you found
oh my God
mother two four thousand five hundred
Super Mario box two three two thousand
three hundred
what are you gonna do it's spinning
you can't prevent the spinning
you can stop the spinning
you can't stop the spinning you can't
stop this
foreign